ده كان العواجل من السودان ننتقل المؤتمر
الصحفي لنتعرف على المزيد
السلام كلها بنتكلم عن اهميه السلام
واهميه تنفيذه واستكماله لكن هنالك
التعديلات لابد الناس تتفق حوله بين كل
الاطراف بما فيه سالك اطراف العمليه
السلميه هو المكونه العسكريه والقوه
والحريه تغيير القوه الاخرى من العمليه
السياسيه كذلكيه العداله اطار عام في
جدائل اطلاله مما فيها اللجان الحصانات كل
المسائل اللي موجوده عدم الافراد من
العقاب لكن كل هذه القضايا بتتحتاج
لمناقشه عام همم في مشاركه لكل اسر الضحك
فوق الحريه لوحده السودانيين ككل وكذلك
مساله ضحايا فبالتالي لتفصيل حوله قضيه
العداله الانتقاليه ايضا قضيه الاصلاح
الامني والعسكري في كلام كثير انه يتكلم
عن ان الحريه التغيير وداع في الوثيقه
السوريه وفي المناقشات استقلاليه اللي هو
ديت قوات الدعم السريع وعدم الكلام ده غير
صحيح الوصفه السوريه تكلم عن انه لابد من
جيش واحد لكن الجيش الواحد بتجيء في اطار
الاصلاح الامني والعسكري وفي خطوات كثيره
من ضمن ترتيب التنفيذات الامنيه ومن ثم
الاتفاق بين القوات ده حول جداول زمنيه
للوصول لجيش مهني واحد ونص على هذه الامر
في الوثيقه السوريه بشكل واضح لكن القصد
من هذه الخطاب هو محاوله الصدام او جر
البلد للمعاركه بشكل الموجود ان احنا كلنا
بنومين بانه لا يمكن ان نمشي في اي بلد
بيتعدل الجيوش بجيش واحد ولكن هنالك حقيقه
لا يمكن ان نقص كود او نقص حوله كل هذه
اصلاح امني بشكل وصول للجيش واحد
بتطلب نقاش واضح وصريح بين جميع الاطراف
بما فيه قاده هذه القوات والمؤسسات لوجود
حول الجيش الواحد وصول للترتيبات الامنيه
كذلك من المسائل اللي تم وكانت بالنسبه
لناديه مهمه في قضيه اطراف العمليه
السياسيه ودي طبعا برده واحد من العيش
فيها اللي كان رفضنا اهو انا لانه بدي
اقراء للعمليه السياسيه
وبالتالي مثلا الاطراف السياسيه بالنسبه
لنهايه اطراف اللي شاركت في وثيقه السوريه
للمحاميد اضافه لكل قوى الثوره اللي بينهم
فيما فيهم اطراف العمليه السياسيه همم
السلميه اللي كان وقع حركات مسلحه ماجيزه
موجودين في
الوسيفه الدستوريه للمحامين همم حركات
المواقع الاتفاق جوبا الحزب الشيعي همم
الرفاق الاخرى في تجمع المحانيد في كل
اللجان المقاومه دي كل بالنسبه لنا انجزوا
من اطراف العمليه السياسيه لكن القوه
الاخرى او القوه الشارقه كانت مع انظمه
السابق هي مكسوره القوه اللي شاركت في
وثيقه المحامين وما مفتوحه لكل عشان برده
انه عمليه سياسيه في النهايه تكون مصداقيه
وليس عمليه سياسيه بالصوره اللي بتكون فوق
اخراج ومسيطر حوله كذلك من ضمن القضايا
اللي همم الناس تحدثت حوله محاما القوات
المسلحه وهي دي طبعا بيرضوا من المحامي
اللي وارد في الوثيقه السوريه برده عموما
على هذه المحامي انه دين مهام بصوره واضحه
وجيليه وموجوده في الوصيه ضد سوريا
لروعه اللي همم تم اقرار بواسطه المحامي
انك محامي للقوات المسلحه خلال الفتره
الانتقاليه